-Our next guest can be seen
at the Helium Comedy Club in
St. Louis November 2nd and 3rd.
Please welcome
the very funny Josh Johnson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Cool.
How y'all doing?
Everybody good?
[ Audience cheers ]
Okay.
I wish I could say the same.
No, it's just I'm getting older
and I can feel it.
This is rough.
This is --
I've turned into, like,
an old black man but now.
This is too soon.
Two days after my birthday,
somebody just said
something I agree with.
Out of nowhere,
I was like, "Mm-hmm."
That is unacceptable.
I am 40 years
too young for that.
A full civil rights "mm-hmm"
out of my throat.
Every day I'm doing, like,
old-black-man things.
I'll just see a cute couple,
start giving them advice.
I was at a coffee shop.
I saw two people
that looked good together.
I was like, "Y'all take care
of each other now."
Who is this for?
I saw a little kid on a park
bench, shoulders hunched,
looking like he didn't make
the team or something.
I just ran up behind him.
I was like,
"So you just gonna quit?"
Like, this is --
[ Laughter ]
I'm starting to say sayings
that aren't real.
My buddy had a bad day.
He was telling me about it.
And when he got done,
I was like, "Well...
bottom of the shoe ain't nothing
without the top of the foot."
Like...
[ Laughter ]
I don't even know
what that means.
I'm just saying things.
You know, and my friends
have been dating,
and I've watched them
as they date.
And I've noticed a lot of what
people call red flags, right?
And people have to
look out for red flags early.
Like, ladies, you know red flags
that we don't even register.
You really do.
I was at a club with my friend.
He had a real
rom-com experience.
He saw this woman
across the club and he said --
He was like, "The light
was just shining on her
a little extra," you know?
And so he made his way
towards her,
and the dance floor was parting.
People were getting
out of the way
as he was walking up to her,
and he walks right up to her.
He lays his thickest game.
He's like, "Hey, how you doing?
Maybe I'll buy you
a drink or something."
She turned around
and she looked him up and down.
She was like, "Oh, uh, no."
[ Laughter ]
"No, it's not for me.
That's not what we do."
And he tried one more time.
He was like, "Why can't I buy
you a drink, get to know you?
Maybe we might like each other."
And she looked him up
and down again and she said,
"Your shoes."
I know that sounds super rude.
It sounds vapid, materialistic,
but I'm not going to lie.
I'm on her side,
because when he looked down,
both his shoes were untied,
and it's like,
yeah, that's a red flag.
There's no better way to walk up
to a woman and be like,
"You gonna have to take care
of me eventually,"
than to walk up
with both your shoes untied.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
How'd he even make it across the
dance floor without tripping?
And I'm trying to be fair here.
One shoe could
happen to anybody.
We're all human.
Both shoes have not happened
since the third grade.
If you approach a woman
with both your shoes untied,
you might as well walk up
with a glass of milk in one hand
and a cookie in the other
talking about,
"You want to be friends?"
'Cause that's what you look
and sound like
when both your shoes are untied.
I'm very blessed to be here,
by the way,
I -- This is absolutely amazing.
I'm --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I grew up in Louisiana
and I feel like
I had an incredible childhood,
even though I don't come
from money, you know?
And I was having a conversation
with my friend.
He gave me
a really interesting metric.
He said, "You can tell how good
someone's childhood was
in the States by how long
they believed in Santa."
[ Laughter ]
If they were told about Santa
and they believed in Santa,
how long they believed
is how coddled,
you know what I mean,
just how sheltered they were,
because we all remember
that kid...
that was like 15.
[ Laughter ]
And Christmas comes around.
He's like,
"I can't wait for Santa."
You're like, "Oh, no.
Oh, they too good to him.
This is terrible."
I had an incredible childhood,
but I'm not going to lie.
I stopped believing in Santa
pretty young,
because when you don't have
a good money situation,
you usually don't have
a good living situation.
So my neighborhood
was really rough.
And when I was 8 years old,
I saw Santa get robbed.
[ Laughter ]
And I started asking questions.
I was like, "How does he
make to every house
in the entire world in one night
but he can't get away
from these dudes?
'Cause he is getting whupped."
[ Laughter ]
I had to call 911
at the beginning of this year.
And I appreciate just about
everything that these people do.
They are literally heroes,
you know?
The only thing
I don't appreciate
is how calm they are
when they pick up.
That feels disrespectful
to my situation,
'cause I'm not calling to chat.
Something traumatic
just happened in front of me.
And I call, and they pick up,
and they're like, "911.
What's your emergency?"
It's like, "No, my tax dollars
cannot be going
to that department store
customer service level energy."
Alright? I'm freaking out.
I need you freaking out, okay?
It would feel better to call 911
and be like, "Oh, my goodness!"
And they're like, "What is it?!"
That would feel so much better.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Because don't get me wrong,
I get it.
They're calm so that I'm calm,
because if I'm calm,
I'm a better communicator
and they can more effectively
help me with my situation.
I understand why they do it.
It just doesn't feel good.
'Cause then you tell them
everything that's going wrong
and then they repeat
your emergency back to you
like a fast-food order.
They're on the phone like,
"So you telling me...
...that your friend fell out
and now he on the ground
and you don't know
if he breathing.
And so you put a spoon
in front of his face
and the spoon fogged up,
so he might be breathing.
But that might also be
your breath
'cause you were too close
to the spoon."
I'm like,
"Just send somebody, please."
And nobody talks about it,
but if 911 doesn't believe you,
they can just hang up.
That's a real thing.
If they don't take you serious,
they think it's a prank,
they can just hang up.
And I know that because
when I was 8 years old,
I called 911 to tell them
that Santa was getting whupped.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
And they hung up in my face.
They were like, "So you're
telling me that Santa --
Sir, we have real things
to do here."
I'm Josh Johnson.
Thanks so much.
Y'all have a great night.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Josh Johnson.
See him at
the Helium Comedy Club
in St. Louis
November 2nd and 3rd.
We'll be right back, everybody.
Come on back.